hey guys jake here with the game spot
news update sounds like those rumors
were true the PlayStation 4 is finally
getting that price cut PlayStation 4
consoles will be available from three
hundred fifty dollars in the US to 450
in Canada from October ninth this
confirms earlier reports that a fifty
dollar price cut was on the way Sony
said our goal at PlayStation has always
been to provide the best gameplay
experiences at the best value we feel
this new compelling price will open the
doors to even more gamers that have yet
to purchase the system the price cut
will be reflected in upcoming bundles
including the black ops 3 1 terabyte
star wars battlefront and NHL 16
packages at TGS 2015 sony announced a
price cut for the playstation 4 in japan
following the event xbox boss Phil
Spencer said he expected the playstation
4 price cut in North America possibly in
time for the holidays and has proven to
be correct the playstation 4 launched in
november 2013 for four hundred dollars
and is remained at this price until now
by comparison the xbox one debuted at
five hundred dollars with a Kinect
camera but later dropped to four hundred
and then again to 350 where it stands
today for the base model without
connects if you haven't made the jump to
current gen by now it sounds like now
might be the best time to do so for more
news reviews and much more stay tuned
gamespot com
you